Silence jump scare Hello,
hello, hello, howdy, welcome in, welcome Hello, hello,
sorry, much later stream than I usually do And also,
surprise-ish stream, I did say that after Faname stuff that
I would probably stream.
So here I am.
But it was not, not, it was, I put this waiting room up like
an hour ago.
Oh, chat is stuck.
Thank you.
Da-da-da-da.
There we go.
Road!
I'm feeling sick myself with a fever and a cough since
yesterday but curling up on my couch.
Listening to Minto helps a lot.
Hope you feel better soon.
Road!
No!
I hope you feel better soon too!
one more joke one joke one more month before i'm no longer
the joker it's not the joker ashes it's it's i think i wrote
the juggler actually i'm going to pop a um cough drop right
now i because i've been uh packing for moving um and also
getting over sick my sick had really stuffy nose and then
all the dust makes my nose even stuffier and everything is
like draining in the back of my throat and it's making my
throat hurt so bad so today we'll be finishing up the game
finish it up the game and uh pretty chill i think typical
jaguar welcome to bamboo Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Number one junkler.
Everybody remember.
Yum.
What is the flavor of cough drop?
Menthol?
Menthol maybe?
Gotta work on those three year badges soon.
How can you get any cuter when you're shining so bright?
Eucalyptus?
Hmm?
What is this flavor?
It doesn't say.
Hmm?
I think it's just...
Flavor.
I think it's just flavor.
What the flavor is it?
Finish planning for Dokomi!
Can't wait to see you again for a second time after Hobshi.
I'm like, yeah!
See you!
there thomas i have another suit pack for the con i was
gonna say are you gonna be kingsman again it's mint the
flavor of the cough drop hello hello hello hello welcome
back lazy competitor thank you so much for two years 24
months flavor is my favorite flavor you know it's also
really terrible about it too that my everything is all
screwy up in my and stuff so I can't taste much right now I
tried I tried like sipping some miso soup earlier and I was
like this tastes so bad and then I tried some potato chips
and I was like these there's no flavor I was like I can't
taste anything oh no but it I am intelligent thank you
though but it's great when the taste comes back yeah i'm
looking forward to that part i usually get frustrated and
then eat a chunk of ginger oh does that help sounds spicy
too but yeah sorry i saw if you hear me sniffling and
snuffling it's just sniffling all over the place that's me
oh yeah that is i mean of course it's me Curly and the twins
need their father.
Curly and the twins.
Thank you, Rickadans.
Thanks for coming to see me.
I had Fandomate today.
Meet and greets in the panel.
Q&A panel.
And it was really, really fun.
And I got to name Rickadans, Fumos, all three of them.
Tweedle, what was it?
Tweedle, no.
Minto D, Minto Dum.
and curly.
My Minto goods are right today.
The Fumo is so cute and huge.
I was not prepared.
I keep warning you guys.
The slippers are so cute too.
Everything is so cute.
I'm so glad you think so too.
Thank you, Taki.
So thank you.
Ginger is a natural anti-inflammatory.
And best of all, so is garlic.
I love garlic.
I'm a garlic girl.
Sorry, we didn't believe you.
you'll believe me believe me i'll be listening to the stream
while running 12 kilometers for charity good luck jay oh my
gosh good luck well then let's get into the game we're back
as will um
yeah i'm not sure quite sure how much i have left of the
game to beat but how long to beat said
We'll see.
It could be a shorter stream.
I hope that's all right for you guys.
Finished up a Densetsu poster mod for Subnautica 2.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
We need it so when we play Subnautica together.
Yeah.
So, quick recap of this game.
We are a game and a game.
And, uh...
We're playing this...
Here, we'll watch the intro again.
Somewhere beyond the Blood Rock Mountain and through the
deadly valleys of great...
The architecture was not this guy's passion.
It lies.
Known only by legend as the forbidden dungeon where you play
forbidden solitaire.
Daring enough to plunge its depths may unlock the sea.
It's like Babby's first Sims home.
Fan of brutalism.
Ah, yeah.
The question is...
Starting Minecraft house looking at a dungeon.
Yeah, that's what I mean!
To you and to meow forever.
I love the way he's throwing those cards.
We just beat her.
Wait, those are all three of the bosses we just beat, so
that's very interesting.
Maybe we're closer to finishing than we think.
So quick recap on this game, we are playing Forbidden
Solitaire, which is a, um, which is a old...
Did it do that before?
That was kind of weird.
Yeah, in this game's universe, an old, like, 90s CD-ROM game
that we found that, like, we had always wanted as a kid, and
we're telling our sister, and our sister's, like, looking
into the game and, like, there was a lot of controversy
about it oh did it again controversy yeah scary copy pasta
the game yeah it's like a creepy pasta and uh so she's
looking into it um people like people uh protested against
the game and turns out that the game is uh tangentially
question is somewhat related to a cult and people sometimes
people People played it and they died.
Thank you.
I forgot the term creepypasta.
I know what you meant.
Is this like inscription?
I've not played inscription, so I'm not quite sure.
But if it is, then I want to play inscription.
It is like a form of solitaire.
Let's continue.
I have to also remember how to do it.
So we just beat...
We just went through a bunch of labyrinths and stuff, and we
just made it to...
I think what is the final door or the final dungeon perhaps?
Yes, play inscription.
I usually, I get pretty nervous about playing card games
because I don't quite understand them so easily usually.
But...
If you guys think I'd like inscription, I'd like to play it.
The game is good at teaching you.
Is it?
Okay.
Because I've watched people play it before and I would just
watch with like a blank expression of my...
face like what's going on oh oh what's going on what's
happened
i saw i saw a video the other day that was like it was oh my
gosh let me know if you've ever felt this before where like
someone explains how to play a game and everyone else around
you learning how to play and start like playing the game and
then you are just like you're just stuck there like at
starting point and you're like i don't understand nimi thank
you so much for the all right everybody hello naplings nimi
i think you would really love this game if you haven't
played it yet we're single choice thank you so much for the
gifted i guess you have to thank you for the gifted!
Roku Rumble!
Thank you for the gifted!
Hello!
Thank you so much.
What?
I saw you were streaming.
But what was she streaming?
Spank, thank you!
Thank you, paperbacks, thank you, ducky, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
She was doing the D-L-E's.
And Tomodachi live.
Oh, that's right.
That's what I watched.
It was like the Costco.
I came in and she was talking about some sort of plate.
And I was like, what the heck is that?
Trash plate.
Yeah, Costco door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've never even heard of the trash plate before.
plate doesn't oh that was scrandal i don't know anything
invisible moose thank you kate barton thank you garfunkel
thank you fork thank you so much phil thank you so much
thank you everybody for all the gifted they should throw a
bunch of food on a plate oh really that's it but the garbage
plate you should play scrandal sometime it's fun okay Seems
silly.
Silly's my middle name.
When I came out of the womb, I was a joke.
Garbage plate was my nickname in college.
Uh-oh.
Mint silly phantom.
That's me.
Zoomers love Scrandall.
Wow, I want to try Scrandall.
Mint silly freak phantom.
Oh yeah, that's true too.
That's so true.
But yeah, welcome.
We're playing a game.
I actually just did, like, the kind of summary of it.
But essentially, it's a game within a game where we're
playing a cursed solitaire game associated with some sort of
cult.
If you beat the game, you die, I guess.
Mint Silly Phantom.
MSF?
MSF.
Oh my gosh, it was fate!
Yeah!
But, um, it's like kind of spooky and, but mostly fun.
Spooky and fun.
I like card games.
But, uh, we just started, so...
You missed nothing besides the first part of the game.
Which was a different stream.
But yeah, let's get into it.
Um, at last, you managed to break the door spell.
It swings open.
as they step within you observe a long dark tunnel lined
with luminous diamonds as held up and held up by haphazard
support beams echoes of deep chanting voices bounce off the
chasm walls oh that's right we saw the cult you've entered
deeper into the mine the chanting grows louder the diamonds
seem to blaze brighter with every word and tone there they
are guys meet me in the mines tonight at nine
Peering around the crate, you see them.
A group of robed figures on their knees, all chanting in
unison.
In the center, a statuesque man towers over the others,
leading them in concert.
What are they singing?
Freebird.
Fan-freebird.
I just played this when it came out a few weeks ago.
I played with a friend who likes Solitaire, and I love 90s
retro FMV games, so we both won.
It gets the atmosphere perfectly for it.
It's so good.
What else could they be singing?
Mine in the group, you spot a door silently, carefully.
You journey towards it.
Okay, that's right.
All right.
I don't think...
We have 200...
I don't think there was anything new at the shop, but
let's...
Yeah, look at my blinged out hand, everybody.
Man of blast.
Remove all playable cards in the same row as the target.
Yeah, that's what...
uses mana.
But I don't want to quite use it yet.
We back in the mines, swinging our pickaxe from side to
side.
Side, side to...
Oh no!
Okay, but it's just a warning.
It's just a warning.
We need to get the other key.
Yeah, our hand is pretty gnarly right now.
It ain't doing so high.
Three.
Wait!
I should have done backwards.
Well, it doesn't really...
I can't do the four.
Because then I could have unlocked this.
Here, let's try it.
Ah.
That didn't help either.
It's okay.
I'm gonna do it.
That didn't help at all.
Oh, we're getting really unlucky.
Hey, Minky.
It's my birthday.
I hope you have a great stream.
If it's okay, I'd like to ask for a B-Day song.
I promise I'll save you a slice of B-Day cake.
Rui-Zu Senpai!
Happy birthday!
My voice is a little achy today.
And I have to sing tomorrow.
So probably, I'm so sorry I know singing today.
Happiest birthday ever!
Happy birthday!
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Five.
In the end it did help us!
Awesome.
I think that's it.
Minto singing again at Fandom A Tomorrow?
Yeah, so have a karaoke panel.
Wait, no, this doesn't help me at all.
We might have to use some of our things.
Extra refresh.
Move all playable cards with the same suit.
It's a target card.
Move a targeted playable card.
Or we could use our mana storm, but I kind of want to hold
off on it.
No!
Our hand is so unlucky.
That's fine in my bed.
It's been so fine.
It's been so, so fine.
Yeah.
I could...
Minus one.
It still counted even when...
Okay.
Oh, that was scary.
Wait.
It counts even if it's a storm in the...
That was scary.
That was pretty spooky.
I'm not going to lie.
That was pretty bad.
Yeah, I guess storms are not the stealthiest now, huh?
Meow.
I can't get that seven.
Our poles are not super great.
I
risked it.
Meow.
Our poles are not super great.
We're running out of cars.
Yeah, I tried the storm before and it didn't do that.
So I guess we got pretty lucky.
Uh-oh.
We're about to die.
I have to clear the board for anybody curious.
Oh no!
I missed one!
It's okay.
Wait.
But it doesn't matter because...
Oh!
It doesn't matter.
We have so many sevens.
Enhan.
That's okay.
Thinking about it, I guess it makes sense that seeing
lightning in a cave might be a tiny bit suspicious.
Maybe.
Don't look at the last two cards.
We were not saved by six, seven.
Actually, we died by it.
Like, yes, girl, give us nothing.
We'll go with the nine.
Oh, ten.
Nine.
Okay, okay.
Wish I could get that eight, but no.
Let's go for this one, because we want to get closer to the
key.
Okay.
Four.
No!
I can't grab it!
Oh.
Oh!
What is this?
Remove all duplicate playable cards at the same value.
I could grab this.
No, I can't get to the dying keys.
I can't get to...
Oh no!
Okay, there we go.
And we can do this.
Okay, wait.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, because then you can do ace, king, queen, king, ace,
two.
Okay, wait, okay, so ace, king, queen, king, ace, two.
Yeah!
Yeah, baby!
That wasn't so bad.
Queen.
Wait, I can grab that now.
Okay.
Nice combo.
Yeah, that was pretty good.
That was pretty sick.
That was pretty good.
If I do say so myself.
Meow.
Queen, bottom right?
Stop it.
Okay, watch this too.
Combo, combo, combo.
Oh, dang it.
I shouldn't have used that, but that's okay.
Combo!
We might actually make it alive through this.
We might make it.
Four.
Ugh.
I think I have to mana storm.
So scary!
Change the suit of all playable cards.
Okay.
Once we can grab that...
RJ!
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the rainbow!
I'm so glad we got the meat today!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
No.
That three?
Oh my god.
I don't think Undo again will.
No.
Oh.
It was good to meet you, woohoo!
I can't click it because you can't...
If I hadn't gotten rid of the three, we would have been
fine, I think.
Oh!
I had to revive.
Okay.
Yippee!
Oh my god.
gosh we somehow were saved as he approached the door you
hear faint whimpering on the other side cautiously you crack
the door open and glance within it's gonna be a friend oh
disfigured half crystallized bodies litter the room a
sobbing figure bound by rope lies on a makeshift table you
are overcome with pity oh my gosh Look at them in there.
They're freaky looking.
That whimpering.
Little baby.
Oh, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee.
Behind the door.
Oh, yo, so biggie.
Please.
You close the door behind you and make your way over to the
dismal soul.
This isn't like a dead end, though.
We need to leave.
Oh, of course he becomes...
Their whimper becomes a scream as they glance over and see
you approach.
The chanting outside stops abruptly.
Swiftly, you duck behind the table, eyes fixed on the door.
Silence.
A bead of sweat rolls down your forehead.
The chanting resumes.
You release your paralyzed lungs.
Ah, oh, safe.
I'm gonna stuff this guy's mouth full of dirt.
You redirect your attention toward the bound victim and
begin to examine the ropes.
Ropes.
Oh, there's something there!
Ropes, ropes!
Oh, oh no, we're fighting this guy again.
Wait, he looks kind of different though, no?
Wait, what's in the shop now?
We've got...
Tri-Peak Layout.
Combat Use Only.
Oh, change to Tri-Peak Layout.
Sure.
Oh, cool!
Okay, uh, fight!
Hot Balor lore incoming!
This is our sister.
Check this out.
Whoa, look at the symbol when you click it.
It looks freaky.
The demon Balor was known as the Game Master.
He'd play a card game with you, and if you won, he'd offer
you the gift of eternal life.
If you accepted it, he'd take your soul and trap it in the
cards.
Eventually, he got tricked by a wizard and trapped inside
his own game.
Typical wizards.
He's taken the...
It looks just like him.
Belor the traveling game master taketh.
Any soul that defeats Belor the traveling master at his own
game shall be offered the gift of eternal life and forfeit
their soul.
Oh, me eyes.
Oh, he hast taken me eyes.
Blasted.
Aw, man.
I hate when Belor, the Game Master, takes my eyes.
Anyway.
Let's go after this one.
What's that?
Time something.
Getting temper...
Oh, what's this one do?
Oh, okay.
I have no idea.
Ah, let's do...
Let's do some of this, though.
Change all the sweet...
Their suit's not sweet, sorry.
duplicate playable cards with the same value?
There are none.
I don't think, at least.
No, I don't see any.
Remove all playable cards with the same suit.
There are none.
Oh, no.
What I will do is...
I'll just do this just in case.
I'll do times three.
I will do this.
Wait, never mind.
I won't do that.
No.
Change the suit.
We'll do this so we can grab this.
It doesn't quite matter, so.
And then we'll grab that.
Oh, another key!
Awesome.
Two.
Yes.
Unless.
I want to see what happens.
But are we...
Oh, it's such...
I guess it'd be like kind of similar to what we just had,
isn't it?
And I end my turn.
Spooky.
I did waste those.
That's pretty sad.
Bonus mana?
Nice.
What is...
Oh!
Oops.
Increase health.
For both of us.
Oh, dang it.
On both of us.
Oh, we didn't heal at least.
Whatever.
I guess I could have used that.
Wait.
Oh, this is bonus mana.
Never.
Just kidding.
That was kind of silly.
It's fine.
Wait a second.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, baby.
Okay.
And I end my turn.
What's wrong with those?
What's wrong with this?
Chaos card.
Oh, we can use this if we get...
Oh, yeah, that's right.
Okay, that's fine.
What's this one do?
Oh, we'll do that now.
And then, same suit as the target card.
Yeah!
We're gaming?
And I end my turn.
Ouch.
I'm curious what this does.
Whoa.
Interesting.
We'll save that.
I don't quite want to do that.
That's like a ton.
Okay, interesting.
We kind of just refreshed our field for free.
Yeah, pocket reshuffle.
Yeah, that was pretty nice.
No!
I wanted those cards!
Temporary defense.
Mine will grab them at least.
What the?
No eight?
I don't want to grab that just yet.
Shogunai.
What's this one do?
Bonus.
Hmm.
Beyond comprehension...
Forces beyond comprehension change cards to the same number.
Six.
Oh!
Two.
Dang it.
I was hoping for another...
For like a five or something.
Okay, I will take this one.
I don't want him to take it away from me.
Even if it was no damage.
Whatever.
Oh, I'm so stupid, sorry if I didn't mean to click it.
I'm about to look at this one.
Ah, it's okay.
End my turn.
Ah.
Plans is, does it clean the effects of these, I wonder?
It did!
Okay, cool.
Oh.
I don't see why I die.
You know?
Ouch, ouch.
Ooh, ouch.
What do we have?
Seven?
Five?
Okay.
Maybe we could have gone after that, but whatever.
Five damage, though.
We'll kill him.
Yeah!
Yippee!
You release your paralyzed lines, you examine the ropes.
Oh, okay, more cards.
Sure.
Let's see what we got.
A whole lot of nothing.
Oh.
Okay.
Uh.
I'm awesome!
You think so?
I appreciate that.
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
No four.
No six.
Oh, four!
I guess I could have gone after that seven.
But whatever.
Oh, Yippee!
Okay, awesome.
No ace.
No.
Awesome is my second name.
Minky.
Uh, silly, freaky phantom.
That's it.
Oopsie.
That was my bad.
Oh, dang it.
Ah, dang it.
I hate when the game says that I was wrong.
I hate it.
I hate when it says, You missed.
Just like then.
Sorry, I'm not locked in at all.
Maybe I should have gone after that six.
Oh, well.
Ah!
I should have done it again.
Oops.
Ah, please!
Please, give me something that I could use!
I can't undo again.
Oh, sorry.
We might have to redo this one.
That's okay though.
Yeah.
It's okay.
Lock in, Minto!
I got distracted by the compliment.
Okay, we're fine.
Sands, Frontiers, Freak, still works.
So glad it still works.
So glad.
Nice.
Okay.
See, this is already looking better.
This is already feeling better.
We've already got much more happening.
Sometimes life is just a hand you're dealt with.
Sometimes you gotta restart.
Sometimes you just gotta restart with a different hand.
Oh, that was nice.
Oh, oh!
Kanbo!
It do be like that sometimes.
Oh yeah.
It doesn't really matter, so we'll go with the three.
See?
Thank you.
Uh, are we gonna get anything else?
Uh, I need a six.
Yes, sir.
I need another six.
Or four?
Six.
We're so close.
There we go.
Woohoo!
Does the music in this game sound Metal Gear-ish reminds me
of the caves a bit?
I...
Maybe.
We starting life in another world with a different hand in
Forbidden Solitaire.
Light novel and anime annotation.
Honestly, restarting life with a different cart, like a
different hand.
Wait, why did we free this guy?
Are we stupid?
efforts you managed to loosen the ropes and free the
captive.
Like, why did we do that?
Outside, you hear the chants growing louder.
As they do, the captive's face begins to glow and distort
into crystal-like formations.
You step back, your eyes darting around you.
You notice the other crystal-infested corpses have begun to
glow as well.
The captive groans as a newly sprouted spine-like diamond
column propels their body.
off the table into the air why did we try they look your way
and briefly beckon before sharp crystalline branches
jettison out their fingers right toward you oh no are we
stupid we got more gems spawn an additional skull card each
hand I will buy that.
Increases Joker frequency by 25%?
We are so blinged out, you guys.
He's gonna touch me with his crystals.
He's gonna...
I gotta show him how blinged out I already am.
Hey, buddy.
Look, I'm taken.
My ring finger, my middle finger, my index finger, my pinky
finger.
You can't handle a girl like me.
Okay, so he only has one shield.
That's not so bad.
Oh, yeah, baby.
What's this one?
Getting an extra refresh.
I'll just do that now.
Wombo, combo, combo.
Oh, no!
Sorry, I clicked it instinctually.
I was like, thing, I can click.
What does it do?
Sharp crystalline growths erupt from cards.
Ooh.
Man, I hate when my spine gets infested with crystals.
Such a hassle.
I know.
And on a Tuesday.
Why not?
Take that.
I don't think...
Oh, what is it, too?
This card shatters when played, dealing two damage to me.
Oh.
Uh, not anymore.
Idiot.
Oh.
Oh, you know what, it's fine.
Let's do this.
Ha ha ha.
So we got rid of those.
Because we're so awesome and smart and cool.
And, uh...
Took down like half as hell.
in one turn.
That should be it.
What's he gonna do?
Six piercing damage on me!
Um, maybe next time.
You need to flex it.
Yuck.
Okay.
Nice.
Re-roll foundation card.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, yeah.
At least we'll get hit for damage.
Well, our health is still completely.
Ouch.
That hurt.
Mmm, a little reshuffle.
No!
Or moves up to two random playables.
Cards.
Okay.
Let's hope that the Ravens take it.
They did!
Holy luck!
Oh my gosh!
How?
How is that possible?
Oh my gosh!
Never punished, baby!
That was crazy!
We're not doing it.
of damage on him so what I will do is shuffle the cards I
was hoping that this would no dang counter we countered
awesome we're close to getting his butt I was oh yes I was
gonna say if I could get one more damage and I think that's
it.
Yippee!
Nice.
With a silent flash, the crystallized captive shatters.
The table is swiftly decorated with their glimmering
remains.
As the dust clears, you notice a strange spine-shaped
crystal staff left in their wake.
You sense an incredible energy emanating from it.
The staff pulsates and hums as you approach it.
Something tells you this staff will become invisible.
valuable soon.
But to wield it, you'll need to bind it to your soul.
Whoa.
What the heck is that?
Okay.
I like how they twinkle.
Oh,
we have more.
Hey, Shannon.
Can I chat with you for a second?
Not really.
Kind of.
extremely busy here Lucas you know I've been thinking about
it and I think it's about time this company put a spotlight
on you in the book spotlight okay what are you talking about
I'm saying and I know this might be controversial huh we put
DC on a brief hold and we put our heads together and ship
one of your personal projects personal projects yeah your
you know forbidden poker no no absolutely not i know it's
sudden but i'm confident it'll be great let me just take a
track at it to see where it's at and we can go from there
out of the question now don't get cold feet i know how you
feel it's scary to be put in the spotlight you know i
remember when my answer is no lucas no she doesn't want to
kill just oh shoot Not just for your sake, you know.
Think about the rest of the team, what it could do for
everyone.
Ouch.
If it's far enough along, it could save.
I think I've got a lot on my plate, Lucas.
A lot of work.
If you don't mind.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Just, um...
Save up.
Okay.
Come on, just whenever...
Yui!
Yeah.
Thanks, Lucas.
You're welcome.
Lucas, mind your own beeswax.
Wicked combo.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Three.
Nothing else.
Uh.
Dang, I wish...
We'll do a...
Ten.
Okay, good.
Nine.
Ten?
Oh.
He's being possessed.
He also wants to play the Forbidden Solitaire.
Alright, come on.
We have to.
Oh my gosh, I have to.
I have to use the card.
Onward?
Your mind is now in harmony.
Your flesh now stable.
What does that mean?
flesh not stable but what is was I melting why am I what
does my flesh stable mean am I a jelly man before what's
happened Lucas is just a poor little guy that's
misunderstood I think he has a lot of passion the staff now
bends to your will what use it has remains to be seen Lucas
used guilt trip it was not very effective Invigorated by the
staff's energies or perhaps guided by them.
You boldly kick the door open, declaring your presence.
It's doom now?
The robed men continue their chanting unabated.
Their task is nearly complete.
The group leader levitates in the air, his head shaking
wildly.
To be fair, wizard skincare probably ain't great.
That's true.
You must take their lives!
Whoa, the wizard guys.
Let's shop, let's see what we got.
Mana chain.
Convert all playable cards into a straight ascending
sequence.
Cost 20.
What?
That's crazy.
Was this one doing nudge?
Increased value of targeted playable card.
Oh, like it goes up one.
Oh, raccoon Andrew.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
25 months.
Thank you.
Thank you so, so much.
I should be able to get both.
Yeah.
Nice.
We'll do both.
Let's...
Okay, I'm gonna already mana storm.
Yes!
I was hoping it would...
Oh, dang it.
I was hoping.
Magical barrier that grants four temporary defense for one
turn.
No!
I don't want them to do that.
Okay.
No!
I think I have to.
Ouch.
Why could I either do the...
Yeah, we'll go with the 9, 8, 7.
I think that had more than going back to the joke.
Jack.
Okay, I think that's everything.
And I...
Oh, they still took damage though.
What's this one?
Siphon help.
I don't think they can now.
Right, probably not.
Let's take that.
No!
Deflect!
Nice.
We'll do this for...
I could do the birds.
Maybe they'll take like something that...
Alright, it works, it works.
And I'm gonna show...
No, I'll end my turn.
Okay, that was kind of lame.
Dang it.
It's okay though.
It's gone now.
What's this do?
Change targeted playable card to a Joker.
Ah man, I don't want that one though.
Safe and health.
Not anymore.
Why so serious?
I'm also just gonna get rid of this one.
I think when I destroy it, it also hurts them, no?
It's pretty nice.
Oh, and we countered!
This guy is weak sauce.
We got him.
We got this in the bag, baby.
Oh, this guy, he's done for already.
We got him.
He's so dead.
I'm doing overkill at this point.
Oh, well, I guess I don't need it.
I'll take it, though.
Oh, yeah.
This guy's so...
And I end my turn.
You want to know how I got these cards.
Oh, I did that.
I got the achievement.
The robed men's bodies lie scattered across the floor while
their leader's face begins to twist and contort.
Oh, she's ugly!
The man's features twirl inward into a pitch black void.
As dark as the starless heavens, you can feel that a vast
unfathomable distance has been breached.
Not to zoom in.
You sense it.
Something from the farthest reaches of all known life.
It's trying to claw through.
I like how everything sounds so dramatic, and then the music
is, like, super chill.
Twins with Gemini Stone to start tripling mana at combo 10.
What's this one?
Doubles mana storm damage.
Single use.
I think we can take both.
Ah.
Gemini Stone and Gemini Stone 2.
Yeah.
Alright.
40!
Draining...
Oh.
Vortices?
Fake say on cars weakening your attacks.
Okay, so it seems like there's been urban legends
surrounding this forbidden game thing for a while.
I just found this one from 1979.
This one was an arcade cabinet.
But the story is always the same.
A game that kills you if you finish it.
You, uh...
You aren't still playing the game right now, are you?
Uh...
No, sister!
They broke into a warehouse to find a mysterious game that
kills.
An occult hideout?
Weird world news.
His eyes were gone.
They were gone.
Spooky bonus.
A gray alien spotted.
Game over.
An arcade cabinet killed my friend.
Gone, gone, gone, gone.
His eyes were gone.
His legs were gone.
His pinkies were gone.
gone his nose was gone everything taken from him except his
pocket change more at world weird weird world news tonight
i'm not even responding to her i'm so gone i'm so lost she
doesn't understand i'm just too good at the game like they
didn't make it easy on purpose i'm just awesome i want to
take it but i I won't.
Um...
If we up it to eight...
Oh, it's not my card.
It's one of these.
I see.
Okay.
What the hell does that mean?
Basic attack damage by one.
His pocket change and his dignity.
Oh, the dignity!
Does this hurt?
Ouch.
easy to get distracted by instant gratification.
Aww.
Oh, I crit!
Nice!
A bloody conduit that drains you of five health.
Nope.
Getting an extra refresh?
Yep.
You and then you.
Where's the...
Oh, the he is here.
Hmm.
Why not?
Nice!
Oh, that might actually help us out a little bit.
Because it's five.
You know what?
I'll take it.
And I'll do that.
And I'll do this.
And a little bit of that.
And I... And my turn!
She's doing Oh,
okay, I was going to say, did that not do damage to him?
Six!
No!
Oh, five.
Wait.
Holy cow.
Oh, my gosh.
That got around is...
That was...
That was probably stronger than anything that we could have
done.
He is a tanky guy.
But we're also tanky.
What's this one do?
Oh, okay, it weakens the card.
They always do it on the cards that I need.
Frustrating.
Let's, um, I wish I could get rid of this.
Okay, I'm just gonna use it.
And we're gonna grab this.
And hope that they take the...
Close enough, baby.
Oh, no, but I...
Well, I guess I wouldn't have gotten the floor anyway.
Wait a second!
Oh wait, did I need that?
No.
I was stupid.
Oh, I did it again.
Square, we're a thornelated.
Thank you.
Oops, I...
I never learn.
I just click, I just click and I get excited.
Wait, why is my damage minus two?
Oh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Click and clap when things happen.
Exactly!
It's so easy.
It's so fun.
I will.
Not reroll.
Oh, I'll hope for like a seven.
Yeah, it's kind of stinky.
Stinky hand.
I'll do that at least.
Kind of stinky hand.
We'll get some damage in at least.
Oh, no, I meant to...
Oh, yeah.
You know what?
That's fine.
Reroll.
The thumbnail is so cute?
You think so?
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Now this removes...
There are no duplicate cards.
Well, ain't that just...
So, so sad.
Oh!
If I don't get above...
six it's like there's nothing you know
stinky no is this the yeah um oh what's this one turn all
cards face up i can't use that let's do this
Get rid of that.
Do that, do that.
Oh, I grabbed that.
My health is still okay.
I can't reroll.
So we're kind of like stuck.
Wait, we can do that.
Oh, wow!
Lucky Paul!
Holy cow!
The leader lies limp in the air.
Their lifeless corpse now simply hinges off the static,
swirling vortex that was once their face.
Oops, you did it again.
You clicked the wrong card, but still won the game.
Because you are just awesome.
Thank you, Dargoo!
Yet the vortex continues to grow.
And grow.
Then you see a brilliant...
star-like being begins to emerge you can feel pure hate
emanate from its presence Wow how witnessing it feels like
blasphemy what are you talking about this is the wonders of
life this is the birth of the baby
cosmic alignment forces beyond comprehension change cards to
the same number four Ouch, yelch.
Whoa, we can see everything now.
Crazy.
Actually, it's kind of overwhelming.
Wait, it feels not great.
I'm gonna do one more.
Yeah.
Oh, I guess I could have done that.
Joker, but...
Not Joker, Jack.
I end my turn?
Everything is fours?
Oh, what do you do here?
Weakening my attacks.
Yeah, it's harder to see options now.
Yeah, it kind of was not great.
Um...
I didn't really need that.
But...
Oh, wait, I was thinking five.
Dang it!
I could have...
Everything is four!
I end my turn And we'll mana storm Double damage Deal 8
damage with a single mana storm Let's go What do you do?
Oh yeah Not anymore
I don't think I have I don't think I had a single Yeah we
deflected Good good
Yeah I did get that gem Yeah Yeah.
Um.
Do I have a three?
No.
What if everything is the same?
Wait.
Here.
Three.
And then we can go to four.
And then.
No other three.
Sad.
That's okay though.
We'll at least get in two damage here.
Right.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah, behind the two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thanks, guys.
Let's do this so we can grab these two.
Nice.
And then...
I want...
Maybe we can get lucky.
We'll grab this four.
Dang it.
I was hoping we would get lucky because I want this
insta-kill before I reset.
Dang it.
What?
Look at that.
Wait, what does this one do?
Oh, okay.
Grab that.
King, queen.
Okay, we're getting crazy.
Combo now.
Jack 10, 9 More health 10, Jack Oh my god, wait, we're doing
Wait, we're gonna do crazy damage in a second Change the
target to play I think that's it Skin Skin Kim!
You unlocked a special Joker, increased temporary defense by
99.
For one turn!
What?
That sounds OP!
Somehow you've done it.
You can feel this being's incredible hatred wane as it
begins to shine brighter than you thought possible.
We're getting flashback.
Hold on, I'm also gonna...
I want a cough drop, but...
Here, I'll use one of these.
It's like the back of my throat, you know?
Your eyes radiate with pain as an astonishing white flash is
accompanied by a deep muffled tone.
You begin to wonder, have you been blinded?
Whoa!
And softly and slowly an ocean of stars stirs in the view.
What the?
Drifting planetoids.
An endless carpet of water.
This game really feels like eternal darkness, weirdness
happening.
An endless carpet of water.
An entire hollowed cosmos unravels before you.
Profane, yet inspiring.
You feel the staff's energy is urging you to press forward.
Somehow we're still able to shop.
When we have targeted playable cards and up to two beneath
it.
I'll take that.
I want to get, I feel, I have more, I have more space on my
fingers and my hand, please.
I want more jemmies.
I'm not done being blinged out yet, please.
Hey, so if you're playing the game right now, can you do me
a favor and stop playing it?
I usually don't believe in this kind of stuff, but I'm
honestly getting freaked out now.
Oh, no, my sister is trying to get it.
I ignore her.
I'm a terrible big brother.
What the heck?
Terrible, big brother.
Should be good.
She doesn't understand the thrill.
She really doesn't.
She doesn't understand me.
The thrill.
I'm sorry.
I can't stop.
She also doesn't know how good with the game I am.
She's telling me to turn off the console.
It's like, shut up, Colonel.
Oh my god.
Get it.
Yeah, it'll be fine.
Yeah.
Why would they kill me if I'm good at the game?
Instead, they would send me to the championships, right?
Obviously.
There's, there's, why would they kill me?
Okay, we need a queen.
And hopefully another queen.
Oh, there we go.
Time to explore.
Explore.
The championships are in hell.
Time seems to flow differently here.
You don't know if you've been traveling these planes for
days or mere moments.
But eventually you find yourself in front of a great gate
with glassy walls, stretching off for what seems like miles
on either side.
listen to her she just doesn't know and we don't have a
problem we can stop at any time we want yeah so what if my
eyes pop out of my head it's from gaming this is where you
need to be you know you must get through
body he looks like the guy in minecraft the iron golem as he
approached the gate a vaguely humanoid jumble of orbiting
crystals emerges before the gate, blocking your path.
It doesn't speak, but you know it wants you to turn back.
The staff rumbles.
You won't turn back.
It!
Oh, we're fighting it?
More jemmies?
Yes!
Plus 5% chance to inflict a critical hit.
Complete the...
a knight ring.
Oh my gosh, it's called a kryptonite.
That's so funny.
After starting a combo, basic attack steal, one extra
damage.
I didn't even see that space there.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so bad.
Wait, I like how we're not even in the dungeon anymore.
Yes.
12, but he has four permanent defense.
Sharp crystallite, okay.
Okay.
Oh, uh...
Let's do...
This.
Yeah.
I'm like, do I- I thought I had- I thought I had a, uh...
We'll do that.
Um...
I don't need that quite yet.
If I do this, does it hurt him?
Oh, it did!
Nice!
And, um...
Okay, that was nice.
That was cool.
But we need more damage.
So what I will do is...
If I do this, I don't quite need it.
But it's a strategic pole.
like so then that should give me yeah 6 plus 1 so that would
give us a little extra it was just strategic strategic pole
dang we got like nothing
this one's oh okay there we go nice 10.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Delay!
Oh, wait.
Why did I freaking do that when I just grabbed?
Sorry.
It's fine.
I'm such an idiot, everybody.
You can make fun of me right now.
You can make fun of me.
That was a really stupid move.
Oh, my gosh.
Why did I do that?
I want to get in more combos so that we can...
What's this do?
Extra refresh.
Yes, please.
Wait.
It's fine, we won anyway.
It's okay!
It's okay, we're saved!
The crystal conglomerate falls to pieces before you, the
shimmering debris dissolving away into the water beneath
your feet.
move do you push open the mighty gate and resume your voyage
yeah totally part of my plan absolutely you wanted to see me
Lucas yes take a seat uh-oh he doesn't sound happy me
Shannon listen I've been doing some thinking I know we
haven't been seeing eye to eye lately and well I decided I
I've really got to do what's best for the team here.
Uh-oh.
Best for the team.
What are you talking about?
I'm talking with our lawyer.
And technically speaking, we already have the right to use
and distribute for sake and solitude.
Oh my god!
I'm getting distracted.
What?
I told you no.
Right.
But your contract with us states that the company owns
anything you create while under employment here.
Oh my god.
solitaire okay now let's not have to get messy with this you
said it was a side project of yours you said that oh are you
going to make me pull out security footage shannon no way
you're being so stubborn about this i'm trying to do right
by you and this team you know we are running out of options
here shannon this game is our best bet at keeping the lights
on no i it's not mine i didn't
I don't think she was the credit.
It's not happening, Lucas.
Fine.
I guess we're doing this the hard way.
If you don't want to help the delusion, I'll gladly do
whatever it takes to keep the vision alive and our heads
above our.
Oh my god.
Are you firing me?
Oh no!
Lucas, why?
Oh no.
That's how it gets published.
roll okay we need a nine or a six oh thank goodness the
dream the dream of prophets the dream of making it big I
mean it's not the fact that he didn't know that it was
cursed I mean I'm sure if he thought it was cursed then he
wouldn't do it but I think it's more so like he's just not
respecting her wishes That was not very inspirational,
though, guys.
Many months pass, or perhaps seconds, as you stumble across
a strange elevated pillar of diamond mineral, the staff
begins to vibrate wildly.
This is it.
This is where it belongs.
Lay!
Peepy lay!
The staff beams brightly as you bring it closer to the
pillar.
This is its home.
You must bind it here.
The pillar is the penlight.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Are you seriously still playing it right now?
Put the game down and call me, jackass.
Please?
Oh, my poor sister.
I'm sorry.
I'm so...
Look, I have to show her how blinged out I am, and then
she'll understand.
Start each hand with at least one Joker.
Yes, yes, we just have a little bit more room.
Down here.
Please cover the hair.
Let's do...
Okay, I'm going to do this.
Wait, it's combat only.
Shoot.
Uh-oh.
Click this special.
Oh!
Oh, I just...
Oh, shoot.
Well, that was a dumb idea.
That's okay, though.
Wait, I can get rid of like all of this.
Uh, yeah, that was fine.
Okay, grid.
We just took a little bit of damage.
There's no biggie.
We'll do...
I want to do a heart.
But...
We could do this.
Wait.
Oh wait, oh okay, never mind.
It's fine, probably.
And then, um, we don't need...
Oh, we have two combat cards.
I wish we could dispose of them.
That's okay.
I will?
Because we're not in battle right now, I'm just gonna get
rid of that, and then we'll grab that.
Okay.
That's...
That works.
Okay.
Oh, I should have done that one instead, huh?
Dang it.
We'll do this one instead.
Oh, yeah.
Yes, I was hoping for that.
Yay!
Okay, cool.
Nice.
Okay.
Eight.
Seven.
Oh, I thought it would open up much more than it did.
Mm-mm-mm-mm.
We love to see it.
I love to see you.
Yeah,
baby.
That was a beautiful combo.
Four.
Oh, okay.
It's been awesome of how Night of the Chupacabra is stuck in
my head since yesterday's stream has made my commute to work
and back home much better now and faster.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the super time.
Glad to help.
Just don't go too crazy, you know.
We'll use these if we get into a pinch.
Some of these, like, uh...
I like how it sounds like, you know, when somebody patooies
into a...
like a they spit into the it's like a cartoon thing they
spit their tobacco into a bucket and it makes that sound
think that's what I think of every time the spittoon yeah
yeah yeah I think of it every time uh oh we are getting low
on cards though I'll do it two random cards nearby did that
get rid of two random cards?
I don't think it did.
We're so close.
I'm nervous, though.
I think
I have to mana storm if I want to survive this.
Wait, that's so stupid.
Tough spot.
Might as well.
Yeah, honestly, I don't want to have to redo it.
Boo!
Focusing your mind, you are able to bind the staff's magic
to the mysterious properties of the pillar.
The two objects merge, becoming one whole.
It's as if they always were.
I know, we were so close!
The pillar shines brightly as the plane seems to turn on
itself, water flooding inward.
It says, stop playing.
I think that's her spirit.
I think that's Shannon's spirit.
Rising from the bowels of the infinite, you behold a glory
like no other.
Colors seem to divide themselves.
Light seems to bend to its will.
Your eyes commit sacrilege.
Shannon's just...
jealous that we are so good at the game.
It is horrifyingly serene.
Yet you know you must destroy it.
Yeah, it was her again.
Okay, look.
Sorry I called you jackass.
Just indulge me for a moment and stop whatever you're doing
right now.
Please, I'm starting to worry.
I wish that we could at least try to respond.
But sorry, I gotta get blinged out again.
Increases health.
Revives you with 10 health on death.
Now we'll do that.
Yeah.
The blingo is crazy.
I know, right?
I like great.
Six permanent defense.
Depletes your mana by 16.
Well, jokes on you.
I just had to use it.
So I have no mana.
And it's a joke on me too.
Because it sucks.
The music.
sounds like it's going KUGaga Do you hear it?
KUGaga
Oh no, I should have gotten meteor shower
Oh well Kaga Oh, I'm not doing any damage Okay, hold on I
did do one damage KUGaga Okay, here we go, here we go, here
we go, here we go 7, 8, 7.
Okay, that was worth it.
That was worth it.
Because we got to do a bigger combo.
So we...
And I end my turn.
What's this?
Arup from the cards.
Everything is like defense that I don't want to take.
We can take this one.
Let's do this.
Maybe it was a mistake.
I had so much stuff.
Whatever.
It's fine.
Actually, it wasn't that much bigger of a deal, to be
honest.
Actually, that was kind of terrible.
Dang it.
We will do...
This.
Holy moly!
That took out so much!
Wait, I didn't realize.
Ouch.
Okay, he's resting.
That was craziness.
I'm just gonna end my turn.
What's this?
Eight damage?
I don't think so.
I think I'm going to deflect all of that, actually.
Um...
Do I have anything?
I could up this?
Okay.
We'll take that.
Dang it.
Ugh, getting to six combo is so hard.
Now all I hear is goo goo gaga.
I'm just so sorry.
Holy cow.
Counter?
Did I?
It's tough!
It splits your mana.
I really don't want him to do that.
Counter isn't piercing.
We're gonna need some, like, really good cards to get this
guy, I think.
I fear.
We'll reshuffle.
Ah.
It's painful.
Ugh.
I want to take these just yet.
Oh, he took everything from me.
He took everything from me!
Wait, maybe this...
will help some.
Do I have any dupes?
I don't think I do.
Oh, yeah.
I feel like I have to just take them just so I can get extra
stuff, you know?
Otherwise, I'm nervous.
I wish I had a card that makes the value go down.
I don't need so many queens!
We could do...
Wait, hold on.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Uh, that did something.
Yeah?
That's some extra- wait, is this- no, this is not it.
I was about to be like, wait a second!
Do I have any dupes?
No, it's sad.
Oh!
That's pretty good though.
Six.
Okay.
Wait, is this it?
This might be it.
So close.
So stinking close.
I can't refresh.
Ugh!
So close.
This is... Oh, wait.
Ah!
Yes!
Oh, as soon as I flip that floor!
Oh my gosh.
Let's go.
Wham bam, thank you, ma'am.
I'm so good at this game!
The glorious horror cries out noise.
Miraculously, you have heard it.
Its surface begins to crack, revealing a bubbling tar-like
substance beneath.
As it bleeds, a multitude of limbs and faces begin to emerge
through the tar, as if gasping air for the first time in a
millennium.
Toilet?
Shit?
This is it.
You can make it bleed.
Now you must finish it.
oh oh my gosh unknown sender video attachment ew also it has
50 health what is this you may be brave you may be oh my god
it's an ad you will not survive let your cards run and maybe
you'll live to tell you don't need to you don't need to
convince me i'm playing it in a card game unlike any other
orbiting solitaire late intruder late intruder late intruder
late late oh it's saying play it yeah preach it to the choir
you should try streaming that game yeah what a great What
was this last card in here?
I don't remember.
Remove all playable cards in the same row as a target card.
The thing is, it just costs so much mana.
No, why not?
I feel weird if I don't complete it, you know?
Here we go!
Let's show all of our cards.
assist you.
Cacophonous shriek that forces you to drop a random Joker
and deals 5 damage.
Um, I think not.
Except I can't use this, sadly.
Um.
I'll take it, though.
Ouch.
Oh, no!
Wait, I accidentally...
Oh, shoot.
Well, we were gonna tank that anyway, I guess.
So, it is what it is.
I end my turn.
Ouch.
Times three.
This guy's going to be really tough, you guys.
I'm nervous.
Why don't we can't beat him?
I guess I get to live.
Boo!
I don't want to live.
If they wanted people to beat the game and join their cult,
they should have made the game, like, the easiest ever, no?
I think they're really dumb.
Boom.
He's resting.
Like, why'd they make it so...
Why'd they make it difficult?
You know, I wasn't gonna say anything about how you P.P.
laid your yearning staff in the Pillars Hole.
And they became as one.
But after your last joke, kind of figure it out.
They need to be worthy.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe they're just, like, no idiots here.
No, sir.
At least he!
At least he only, you know, has no defenses.
Ouch!
What a useless... Pull!
No, I have no way to deflect.
No!
On that pathetic hit.
Oh wait, we can do here.
Nice.
Okay, alright.
Uh...
We'll do this.
Um...
Yeah.
We can nudge...
This card?
Yeah.
Sure, why not?
I give us an extra extra.
No, my attack is useless!
Okay, there we go.
We got rid of it.
Oh, is this a... yeah.
Okay, cool.
I will do this.
And we'll also get him twice.
Very good.
Okay, that does a good amount.
Mm-hmm.
Not nice.
Go-go-gaga.
Oh, wait.
I have a refresh.
I just realized.
Oh, my gosh.
I guess I countered.
Thank goodness.
Oh.
Scary!
I will turn over all of my cars.
Oh, I lost my health though, that really sucks.
I don't think I can do anything else.
I don't, I don't think I can, yeah.
Oh, I guess I gotta refresh this, but it is what it is.
Um...
Okay, he's resting and I will also rest.
Refresh.
Please, game.
Okay, all right.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ouch, I have to take the hit.
Okay.
Um.
I don't want to do so much damage if I have a weakened
thing, you know what I mean?
I'll try and get rid of stuff.
up first.
Okay.
Like that.
There we go.
Assist you?
Playable Joker.
Oh.
Yeah!
We could do the mana change.
Chain.
Wait.
In a ascending... Wait.
Ascending sequence.
Would that What does that mean?
Oh, oh no, I'm stupid.
I know what it means.
Um, that could be good.
Yeah, actually that might make it so that we win, right?
Uh, five, six.
Oh, here it is!
Are we about to win?
Are we about to beat the game?
And we crit!
Let's go!
You unlock this special joker, create two random jokers.
Oh, I guess not.
Endless pain.
Your mind floods with these thoughts as an explosive stream
of tar begins pouring from the pearly, magnificent god.
In an instant, the tar swallows your whole.
Blackness.
You open your eyes and see a large door sitting at the edge
of the obsidian void.
Graciously, you step towards it.
You admire the door's towering opulence before reasserting
your focus.
You must figure out the way to open it.
Am I getting blinged out?
Yippee!
What do we got?
Gain extra combo damage by playing two cards of the same
suit in a row.
Oh, yes.
We're filling it out.
Please, Will, stop whatever you're doing and answer me!
Please check your connection and try again.
Message failed.
Uh-oh.
Oh, we're...
That's it.
There's no going back for us.
We're completely doomed.
Uh-oh.
Sure, I'll do one more.
Okay, that did nothing for us.
Three.
I wish I had another three.
Wait.
It could.
Hold on.
Let's...
Well...
I'm like, do I want to waste it?
It's not a waste.
Let's do it on.
Yep.
Yeah.
Wait.
Am I stupid?
Oh, I need another three.
Oh.
You know what?
It's fine.
Probably.
Whatever.
Oh, look at that!
Wait, I can only use it on one though.
That's fine.
It's fine.
You can't hoard onto things.
You know, you gotta use them so that you can continue the
game and stuff.
I was gonna say, this hand is so dukey, I'm getting nothing.
Synergy.
I'm gonna do this.
Okay.
Some folks lose to the slots, some to blackjack or the
races, but imagine getting swept up in solitaire.
How do you explain that one to family?
They don't know that it's really good solitaire, okay?
If only they knew.
These fools!
They don't understand me.
Okay.
Because their small, feeble brains don't know.
They don't know what they're up against.
And how great I am!
The Solitaire.
Wait, this is like kind of...
We might have to redo this one.
We'll see.
We'll see what happens.
Actually, we could do this.
Oh!
Wait, that was so worth it!
Removes all playable cards with the same suit as the target
card.
I don't see why not.
We're kind of getting...
Well, we're not getting close to the end of this, but we're
getting in there, so...
I think it's worth using our resources, you know?
Like that.
Yeah, like that.
Uh-oh.
I might still not win, though.
No!
Revive!
Oh my gosh.
We were saved.
But it's still...
I need...
four?
Two?
Oh!
Save!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, well.
Complete the diamond dungeon.
All at once, it begins to make sense.
You twist one piece, pull, shift, and push the others.
The various contraptions of the door all begin working
together in harmony.
The massive door swings open to reveal a long, regal hallway
painted with the most luxurious shapes and materials.
Yeah, was it my time yet?
As you step within, your tired feet are greeted by a soft,
ruby-colored carpet, carving a path through the abyssal
hall.
The Forbidden Dungeons' prized bounty surely awaits you.
at its end.
More bling?
Oh my god.
All face down royal cards.
Wait, Mark's all face down royal cards.
I can only get one.
Turns over 20%.
Royal card is like a king, queen, jack, right?
This one's big.
I think it'll cover more of my hand.
Never mind, we just shoved that right in.
Wait, is this the one of scrying?
No.
This is the gem of scrying, so this probably would have gone
right there.
It's fine.
I'm sure there's gonna be a big boss baddie, so...
So that's it.
There's nothing you can do.
I told you already.
make it even if that's true unless you have a way to prove
it I'm afraid the security footage Heartblade sent over of
you saying otherwise is going to be sufficient evidence so
that's it then they're just gonna release it it seems that
way that's it they did send over a rather generous offer
you'll still collect 10% of the profits and receive credit
as the lead developer I don't care about the money I need
this shut down well I'm not sure I see a path forward on
that you don't understand it can't be released it's
dangerous well if it's any consolation any potential
liability would be on their hands not yours we can ask for
them to remove your credit perhaps forget it just forget it
you've been no help i i'll figure something out
Hello!
I got raided!
Thank you so much!
I didn't see who it was.
But thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Hello, hello!
Strike Warlock, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Not well.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
Torgo, thank you so much for the 5 gifted!
What?
Thank you so much, everybody!
Thank you, thank you!
Um, welcome to Forbidden Solitaire, but we are a bit at the
end of the game, it seems, maybe.
But, um...
the craziness.
Oh my gosh, finally, a key for that.
Um.
Let's do... Wait, what is this?
What is that?
That's an icky looking card.
Unless it's the thing that's marking it as like a royal
card.
Is that what it looks like?
Ew.
Nice.
I used to...
Oh, yeah, it was.
It was a marked one.
I see.
Ew.
Why does it look so gross?
Secret revealed.
Okay, we just got to get rid of the rest of these.
Um.
Please, like, a king or something.
Oh, thank goodness.
Thank goodness.
What does this one do?
Oh, yeah.
Ah!
So lucky.
So, so...
I've been getting really lucky on these past couple of
games.
Holy cow.
I do have to...
I'll be right back, though.
I do have to get some tissue for my nose.
I don't want to keep...
Yeah.
Okay.
I gotta go blow my nose.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
All right, let's continue forward.
Scatter, no!
No, stay, please!
Stay, where are you going?
I'm spooky, but you don't need to be that scared.
Aren't you used to be?
me by now come back welcome back thank you let's continue
forward with every footstep you hear deep rhythmic rhythmic
echoes bounce through the wine tinted gallery then in the
distance a metallic glint my crown walking closer you at
last behold a terminus with the hallways and finally in
sight you see it a shining crown covered in empty notches
nestled on the seat of a throne
leading up to the throne are four ominous stone statues
their glassy eyes seem to follow you as you approach oh wait
is this a boss rush as you pass near you can't help but look
up at these granite golems with awe the first statue you
pass appears to resemble a prestigious dressed aristocrat
with two radiant green gems for eyes oh it matches your gaze
oh no stone scrapes stone as the stiffly effigy contorts to
grab you okay I guess we're fighting all four of these guys
okay yikes 60 suit locks fastened upon cards causing three
damage oh my Okay, um, before we do this, okay, now I'll do
it.
Okay, another instant.
Okay.
Do that.
Do this.
I don't know.
Do I need this?
I can't really tell.
We'll grab two.
Three, four, um...
The music, though!
Grab you.
And then a target.
We'll do this one.
Nice.
Just chip away a little bit.
A little bit.
Okay.
And then if it's gonna...
Not quite sure.
Remove all playable parts with the same suit.
We could do...
I'll save.
We'll combine these.
Wait.
So this one will change the suit.
And then this one will get rid of all of them.
Oh, that sucks.
Yeah.
Like, oh, I should have grabbed Bad Queen instead.
I'm an idiot.
No, I was hoping.
Still resting.
What's this?
Total damage 8 plus 1 is increased by each playable royal
card?
Uh.
Wait, I can grab it?
Ouchie, ouchie.
I have nothing left, though, really.
He's gonna deflect everything because I can't do any damage
to him.
Okay.
Goodbye.
This is a lot if you really do have to fight all four of
them.
Right?
That's what I'm thinking.
Okay.
Good night to that one guy.
Good night to the one guy.
Good night.
Unmove a playable card.
I wish the mana cards gave me more than just two at a time.
Ugh.
Oh, I can't...
Oh, no.
That unlocked another queen.
Oh, I did.
counter though awesome we take those it's gonna this is hard
this is tough
we'll delay it because i don't want him to lock anything
like their moves are kind of crazy oh wait oh king
okay oh i wish i could do the 10.
End of my turn!
Oh, it does the damage.
I forgot about that.
Well, shoot.
I can't really do anything.
This sucks.
Oh, at least that unlocked it.
I got more water, too.
Ugh.
They've given me nothing, too.
Like, nothing to work with.
Oh my god.
Ow!
What the hell am I supposed to do?
This is evil!
Okay.
Do you want me to join your cult or not?
Oh.
I can't do any damage.
I can't get anything in.
They could barely even lock it.
Like, you can tell the game knows that I have no, like,
anything.
And gives me only things that I can work with at the moment.
At least the game is kind in that regard, where it's just
like, oh yeah, we know you can't play anything at the
moment.
I'm gonna die here, everybody.
This is it.
Pity system, yeah.
Is there stuff in the shop I can get?
Oh, I can buy this now.
Oh, it's stuck in right there.
Oh, I thought it was gonna go here.
Just kidding.
Okay.
We will do that.
Is it causing three damage?
I want no damage.
How about none?
Okay, what if we do this?
We're just gonna change everything to this.
I could have saved it, but it's probably fine, maybe.
Maybe.
It's okay, whatever, who cares?
I don't need that right now.
Oh, deflect.
Counter.
Err.
If I do this...
Kind of counted.
Kinda.
What if I...
What if I do this?
There we go.
There was some one that at least...
Oh!
Okay, we at least were able to get more damage in.
Oh, and we crit!
Awesome.
I feel like you get more most use out of it right away at
the start anyway.
I agree.
That's why I did it like that.
Please, game.
I'm grasping at straws here.
It's giving me nothing.
Yes, queen.
Give me nothing.
Well, at least do that.
And then no damage.
No extra damage.
I might be able to get, like, a mana storm in eventually or
something.
Nice!
We take that.
Oh!
Mana storm!
I haven't been getting, like, the ones that...
Do, like, the...
Costs mana to do this, so...
Um...
Okay.
This is already maybe a little better, maybe.
We'll hold off on those.
Okay.
Yes.
Uh...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, oh, oh no!
If only...
Wait, it's 8 damage, right?
Okay.
8 plus 2!
Oh, 8 plus 5!
Oh, we are screwed!
What the hell?
Because I have so many things up here!
Yikes.
Ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
That did crazy damage to me.
15 more.
Yeah.
We need to get really lucky though.
We need to get pretty lucky if we want to get out of this.
Nice.
Hey.
Oh, no.
Ouch!
I didn't think he would do it.
I thought I'd be okay.
Oh, we won!
I wasn't even gonna...
I wasn't even gonna try anymore.
Unlock all of the jokers!
Multiply.
You unlock the special joker.
Multiply damage by two for one turn.
The statue lies in rubble alongside its two glimmering green
gems.
I stick them in my hands.
You inspect the gems and at a glance, back at the crown's
nine hollow indents.
realize their grander design.
Oh, nine!
With purpose, you march up to the next statue.
This one resembling a tall female monarch.
Her eyes glowing as striking crimson.
There she goes.
We got this, guys.
She looks down on you, almost pitiful as she prepares to
strike.
It is the Elite Four, for real, though.
Big gem.
Gives you extra refresh.
We are so close to getting all of our...
Our whole pan-bad-bad-bad-bad-bad-bad-azzled.
And an extra refresh?
Huge.
Seven damage!
It makes me drop a random Joker!
Okay, we'll have to use all that we got.
And we'll do that, and we'll do that.
Uh, let's use everything.
Queen, no.
We'll do this one.
No.
Well, how about then?
We change.
You.
Oh, nice.
Seven?
We could do it, we could handle it.
Yeah, I'll do the extras too.
Okay.
Nice!
Nice.
Uh-huh.
And she has no shields, so that's not so bad.
The eye.
Multiply damage by two.
We'll save it.
Wait, what did she- She heals herself!
Oh no!
I hate that!
Oh, dang it.
Regal swipe.
This is kind of stinky.
I'm just going to refresh.
Okay.
That makes me drop a random Joker.
So, hopefully I can...
Can I get a good hand in here, please, or something?
Please change to seven!
Yes!
And then we can do the double damage this time.
Five, six.
Times two.
Does this cause damage?
Oh yeah, it does, okay.
Five.
Okay.
Times two.
Nice!
Okay, we're chipping it down.
What's this one do?
What?
Oh, remove all playable cards in the same row.
I don't really have them in rows, though, now, do I?
Yeah, we're getting there.
Imagine if you had crit then.
I know, right?
Yeah, I guess that's why there's no armor, because she
heals.
Oh.
My 10, thank you.
What counts as a row anymore?
I have no idea.
I'm just gonna try it.
Ah.
Okay.
Well, I pulled some more cards out, so I guess that's fine.
And we did damage.
So I'll take it.
That was kind of stinky, though, huh?
Oh, oops.
Um...
She's gonna heal!
No!
We gotta do mega damage!
DG mega damage!
Oh, you...
You bitch!
I'm just gonna refresh.
I think.
Marco!
Thank you so much!
Okay, let's just swipe.
Where the vibe gets to take you!
Thank you so much!
Okay, let's swipe.
And...
Uh...
We might be able to do it.
Maybe.
What if I do it like this?
Yeah?
Okay.
Uh...
I think that's all I can do.
Yo!
The counter!
Yes!
That one was easy.
That one didn't take so long.
Another statue reduced to...
rebel.
Two more gems in your pocket.
You push forward to the next statue, its stony bearded
expression.
Royal robe and pointed crown carve a masculine sovereign
likeness.
Its eyes glow a pearly sapphire.
It looks like Santa, guys.
It stutters down to your face as you to face you as it ready
to besiege.
I thought he was gonna kiss my face.
Silly guy.
What do we have here?
Doubles mana storm.
Use damage.
Yeah, we'll buy it.
I don't see why not, right?
I think...
Oh, nice.
We got a much better pull, too.
What did you do?
Parry for 8 damage if you attack this turn.
But...
This is...
Raw, raw, raw.
We will not...
Then.
We will not, then.
Oh my god.
Wait, she had 70 damn.
He had 70 HP, everybody.
She had 70.
Elevates cards to royal status.
Okay.
And that...
Parts Y?
Sir?
I have these.
I end my turn.
Oh man!
Oh, I had such a good thing going there though.
You jerk.
Oh, okay.
Plus each royal card.
Okay.
10 plus 4.
So let's get...
It's 10.
This is when temporary increases defense by 99.
I don't think we need it right now.
Let's do this though.
Oh, nice.
Crazy, crazy damage.
I wish I had the double damage right now.
Okay, so now it should only be one, right?
Yeah, temporary.
of 11.
Okay.
Oh.
I'll even...
Oh!
Never mind!
Just 10!
Ace King!
Thank you guys!
I saw it before you said it, but I still thank you.
I still thank you!
We're trying to help me out!
Thank you very much.
He's asleep.
And I...
Nice.
A Perry 8.
We shall not attack them.
We shall... Is this what says attack?
So if I do this, it should be fine.
That's right, the double damage.
Blast 200 cards.
Cool.
Let me tell you are very cute.
Thank you, Mr. Yum.
Thank you!
And my...
Torn.
I love it.
Okay, royal status.
Whatever that means.
Okay.
No!
Oh, you didn't you couldn't give me like a few more.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, this is kind of bad.
10 plus 6.
So it would still do 10 damage to me.
We can take out...
We have to hope for like a queen behind one of these.
Behind one of these cards.
Exactly what I just said.
another queen.
Or more defense.
I think another jack unlocked though, which is kind of
whatever.
It's fine.
End of my turn.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Let's do you.
Only one damage.
What is this one?
Change target.
to a joker.
Oh, we'll do this.
Create two random jokers.
I can't do that.
Sad.
Hmm.
Doesn't really matter.
We'll do this one.
Okay.
Nice.
Remember, all playable cards into a straight.
I wish I had.
Okay.
What is this?
Oh no!
Oops, I didn't see what it was.
Ugh!
Ouch!
Oh, I didn't see what it was.
We'll do- oh wait, I don't have the 20.
Dang it.
I think this might be the time to do my 99 defense.
Or...
No, because he'll kill me.
I think...
It'll be...
A ton of HP is a little...
A little...
Get the king first?
Yeah.
Yeah, so we can at least do the combo.
You're right.
You could take one more, save it.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
The game does try to give you, like, more combos and stuff.
It seems like, at least.
It appears that it's trying to give you more combos.
Okay.
No.
No attack.
In fact, I just end my turn.
I will take that.
And I will take that.
And we'll save that.
Wait a second.
Wait, is this it?
Oh.
Aw, me.
Well, we have a bunch of extra cars that we could use next
time.
Did it easy?
Three statues lie in ruins.
One final statue remains.
You take the sapphire gems and carry yourself forward.
The last statue seems to laugh at you, which is unnatural.
With its unnatural, wide-brimmed grin.
Its three-pointed hood and frozen merry pose sculpt the
impression of a royal harlequin.
Where'd it go?
It's embedded in its hat as a sparkling red gem, a green gem
in its right eye, and a blue gem in its left.
You feel- you steal- you steal yourself as the gesture turns
its head towards you.
Its smile fractures, the stones stretching larger.
Is the guy from- from- The devil may cry!
Oh.
They want him to be easy?
Question mark?
Some sort of trick, perhaps?
Oh.
So I gotta say, I can't do anything.
Uh...
I don't know.
The final statue crumbles.
The light.
You take the gems, string not found.
System error!
You have to...
It's too... before it's too late.
Something.
Let's have to stop probably.
String not found?
Uh-oh.
What's with my cards?
Remove all playable cards with the...
Okay, come on, come on.
Seven.
Passcodes changed already?
Damn it.
fine we'll do this the hard way okay it's been a while since
I climbed a tree
what does it do in the combo okay acting funny where'd you
put it Lucas she's taking the she's taking the game back No.
Shit.
Must be in this office.
I need a mana chain of eight plus cards.
It's Shannon.
It's been nice knowing, Mint.
I'll miss her.
You guys are all accomplices.
You're all watching this too, you know.
come on oh there's no time god damn it i love how nonchalant
it's shannon remember the words shannon remember the words
mea animus transferator in hope orbiculum mea animus
transfer They change into cart- wait.
Yeah, they change each time, it's nice.
A little freaky!
There's no music or anything either.
Give me something I can use if you want me to be your little
sacrifice.
I'll be your sacrifice.
Sounds like some sort of emo song or something.
I'll be your sacrifice, little lady.
What do I have here?
Okay.
More?
Uh...
Damn.
Game hates me.
There's no way.
Oh my god.
There's no stinking way.
The boss.
Is this gonna 5 damage?
Me too?
Let me keep today's my birthday!
Hi, Red, happy birthday!
Yes, I could try and do it.
One second, though.
My voice is not so up to...
Up to everything, so I'll just make it fast one.
I'm sorry.
Happy birthday, congratulations!
Happy birthday, wish accretations!
Happy birthday, may your scars stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Paracore!
Happy birthday!
Yeah, there has to be some gimmick, I feel.
Oh, uh...
Okay.
Um, it's a good thing I have these.
Uh...
Wait, what is this one?
And this one.
This one will also heal him too, though, won't it?
Oh, whatever.
Has to be a gimmick, right?
Or something?
What's this do?
Dodge.
Oh, evades the next attack.
If I heal him.
Yeah, we both heal.
Honestly, if it's a gimmick, I'm not quite sure.
Oh, wait.
Isn't this the...
Yeah, I have to use this anyway.
We're going to be dead otherwise.
I countered.
Why wasn't my counter 99?
Hey, you're cheating.
It's kind of over for us.
It's kind of over for us, I fear.
Unless, like, the gimmick kicks in, like, right now.
Oh, wait.
It's going to dodge this one.
That's so stinky.
Yeah, only 974 to go.
Easy.
Oh, good.
I can get in three temporary defense against the 99 damage
that he's going to do.
Cool, cool, cool, cool.
Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
Oh, he also gets it.
Okay,
well...
Do our eyes in real life come out?
Wait, they actually want me to defeat this guy?
Wait, oh, there's something in the shop now.
Cease thy meddling.
Collect all the gems in the shop!
We were set up for failure!
It was scripted from the beginning.
Oh!
Oh, he's much weaker now.
Okay, he's like, actually doable.
Nice!
I will do this.
Oh, wow.
Okay, that's so funny.
It's so funny that you would give me that car.
I will take a bonus mana
Okay, 12 Is much better 12 to 14 Okay Um, there Two We'll
also get more Uh, I think that's all I can do
Oh, wait I should have gone back to the six, but it's fine.
It can bleed.
Oh, I crit again even.
Wow.
It will evade the next attack.
Okay, then I'm not even going to do anything.
Don't mess with me.
If you're going to do that, I'm not going to do anything.
Yes, please.
Thank you very much.
And I'm just going to use it, because why not?
Oh, thank you.
I want this one.
I probably should just refresh, though.
Oh, I wasted my turn.
It's okay, though.
It's fine.
Evades next attack.
We blasted him.
Uh, uh,
let's do this one, this one.
Oh, that was about it.
We can afford to take the hit on this one, probably.
Probably.
Uh, in fact, I'm even gonna use this.
What's this one doing?
Oh, change playable card to a Joker.
Oh, sure.
Okay, next time we refresh.
Actually!
Never mind, we don't need to refresh at all.
And I only have one damage to him, so I'm just gonna use
this.
And then we can tank it.
And, oh yeah, it's my turn.
And Jacob!
Thank you so much for the 20 hits it!
Thank you!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Guys, it was nice knowing you.
It was nice knowing you.
Oh, this one's evaded.
Dang it!
I didn't realize.
Shoot.
It's fine.
It's fine, I guess.
I'm not gonna do this.
I don't feel like I need to.
Oh no!
We got the minus 10!
No!
Do we have any?
Oh!
I'm matching.
Wait, use, use, use it!
Yeah!
And my turn.
I wish I could refresh.
Two...
Oh wait, he evades, dang it.
Uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
It was
nice knowing you all!
I'm about to get my eyes gouged out.
Cool visual.
You will die if you finish it.
There's been too much death already?
I can't let you die.
Oh, me!
Wait, there's even...
No freaking way.
What does that mean?
Ew!
Are we for real right now?
How much longer?
I'm just...
I'm going to use this because I don't know what he's going
to do.
Oh, freakazoid.
What's my damage for one turn?
We got the combo.
Actually, we can use this one now.
We got a good combo going.
I guess that's about it, though, huh?
Oh, wait.
Let's see if two birds can take something and we get more.
Unfortunately not.
Oh.
Okay.
The music is so good.
Yeah,
we'll do that.
Um, we'll do that.
Can I gain even more?
Nice.
12 to 14!
Okay, well we at least have that.
to defend ourselves.
Are we countered?
That's fine.
Oh, this is evade.
Oh, yeah.
Dang it.
Oh, nice.
Not nice.
Everything...
Turned to...
This sucks!
I'm in the... I'm refreshing.
I don't care.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, thank you, thank you.
I hope this is the last one.
Because doing another round would just be overkill, I fear.
Then I would be like, okay, game, come on.
Let's wrap it up, you know?
Five damage.
I can tank it.
Okay.
I can tank it!
Oh.
Nice.
We're at eight?
Okay.
It would be too much clown and...
Yeah.
Okay.
Though I...
Not to say though, I really do like the...
Please, 10 extra!
No!
I do love the gameplay.
So, but I'm excited to see how it ends and how we die.
I'm excited for that part, too.
Okay, he evades, so I end my turn.
I'm just gonna go to the next one.
No, we have, like, nothing.
Not even an 8.
No!
Thank you.
What's this one?
Uh, gain an extra refresh.
I will take that.
Thank you very much.
He's close, though.
He's close.
What does this one do again?
I don't remember.
Oh, change the cards to the same number.
I didn't see my health.
Oh man.
I had this too.
We were so close.
That was such a good hand.
Oh.
No.
Oh, that was such a...
I was doing so good.
That was such a good hand.
I'm so sorry, guys.
Oh, man.
Times three, though.
We'll take that.
Okay.
Yeah, we'll save those.
I tank it.
Take it, man.
You got this.
Yeah, we got this.
We got this.
It gave me no nothing to use.
I think I'm just going to refresh, honestly.
Okay.
It's evade, so I'm ending with her.
it?
The game hates me.
The game hates me now.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
Times five.
Okay.
Let's go.
Uh.
Combo.
Okay.
Um.
I have all these defense, but...
Oh, wait.
This too.
But I am going to use this.
So we can continue the combo.
Another one!
Oh my gosh, we can keep going.
So let's just put that on.
Nothing.
One more time!
I end my turn.
Oh good, we got the plus six.
Okay, awesome.
Hmm.
Oh, I don't know why I thought that would do anything.
Next one, we'll use the thing on it.
Okay, and my turn.
Uh...
I think I have to take it, unfortunately.
Okay.
I'm just gonna use it.
Unfortunately, it heals him too.
I don't want to do that.
Meteor shower!
And my turn?
What is this do again?
Oh, yeah.
Please, plus 10!
Yippee!
Okay.
And then...
No, I think...
We're okay.
No, I'll take it, I'll take it.
Yeah, because then we get the free refresh, you know?
Is that a free refresh?
Actually, not so sure.
Should I tank it?
Free refresh.
Let's just do it again.
Oh yeah.
The wild card.
Let's try it.
Because then...
Oh, I get another extra two?
Okay, wait, this is good.
This is good.
Um, we'll do...
This five.
Dang, I was hoping for a king.
Oh, I should have done the three.
I'm so stupid.
Wait, I should have done the three.
I'm an idiot.
It's okay, though.
Actually...
Did that do much?
I'm not questioning.
sure, to be honest.
Undo.
There's fortunately no undoes.
It's okay, though.
Um, I have eight.
I think we're fine.
I think we can tank it.
Oh, I crit!
I crit!
It's too late to stop it!
My name is Shannon.
Oh.
Shannon's trying to help.
Don't listen to it.
Do not accept its gift.
Don't believe its promises.
Don't believe his lies.
You insert the final gem.
The crown begins to glow gloriously before you.
At last, your prize is at hand.
Slowly, you place the crown upon your head.
My sister is saying finish the game, finish the game, finish
the game.
Anything in the shop?
No, I'm too blinged out.
Okay, never.
Is this it?
Like, this is the last of it.
This is it.
Right?
I have to minigame my way to wearing the crown.
Well, Shannon, if you don't want me to do it, do it so bad
you should like make my game harder it's not my fault I'm so
good at the game
Shannon you should like give me a really terrible hand I
never I never can complete honestly if she wanted to she
could have like done it where like the final hand or
something you know doesn't allow you to play it but no she
didn't do that So, what now?
She did throw a boss at you with 999 health.
Okay, that's fair.
No!
Oh, I don't know why I didn't grab that.
That's my bad.
My crown!
But look how pretty it is!
But it's so beautiful.
I can't help but accept it.
Oh, I should have grabbed that.
It's fine with her.
What if I lose this though?
Awesome.
I need the other key.
Oh, it's here.
Oh, thank goodness.
I was gonna say, the game really is gonna have me lose.
Dang, Yu-Gi-Oh!
Looks wild.
When they say it's time to duel, they're very serious about
it.
like it's time to this beauty does not compare to you what's
with this flattery today huh
where the crown we
got blue screened over here oh that's why he wears the scarf
oh my god he's like the reverse shidime the guy has a
eyeball in his butt and this guy has an eyeball in his eye
oh my gosh are you John Microsoft here to fix my computer
John Microsoft has been a demon this whole time
thou hast completed my game
good so tell me william
dost thou wish to be granted the gift of eternal life now i
think this is a trick if we say no he's gonna kill us and if
we say yes we get eternal life an eyeball in his eye wait
did i say eyeball in his eye i meant in his mouth
here i'll let you guys decide what we do Yes or no?
No.
Yes.
I'll let you guys decide my fate.
Will I die?
Which matter of death?
Are you going to kill me?
Are you going to imprison me forever?
Are you going to imprison me forever in the cards?
I feel like yes will be the more interesting ending but you
guys are saying no it's a trick because Minto is already a
ghost how can he give you eternal life I know but
I'm gonna say yes I mean my crown is so pretty maybe it'll
give us the option to start from here and see the other
ending we'll try yes actually yeah we'll go ahead thou art
wise to accept this gift now please enjoy thine fruits of
eternal living okay you guys have to understand I play
telltale games and they give you the illusion of choice
that's what the poll was the
victim's name was William Roberta found dead in his home
office by his sister Emily the victim sibling Emily Roberta
claims to have become increasingly concerned why is she on
the TV like she looks it looks like she's died having only
sent her one final message before the incident occurred play
the game Emily play retry oh good see it puts us right back
here cool oh it lets you go back immediately that's awesome
so tell me William does dost thou wish to be granted the
gift of eternal life now what what thou hast rejected the
eternal prize the greatest gift imaginable thou dost reject
the mission i had for thee Why?
Because some meddling soul told thee to...
I shall grant thee one last chance.
Thus thou art...
Sorry.
Accept.
I live to be immortalized.
Now!
Thou hast earned it.
Thou hast overcome my game.
Thou must accept thy prize.
Thou must.
The mission shall not die.
Oh, again?
Death picks a card.
What?
I guess we should have known, huh?
We should have known, huh?
This is how it would be, huh?
Yeah.
Oh.
You know what?
Let's do it.
The game is obsessed with you.
And I end my turn.
When the counter on this card reaches zero, you will perish?
I will perish?
Not if I have anything to say about it.
Oh.
It didn't get rid of it.
I do that?
Oh, it actually is a playable card.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Well, shoot.
Oh.
We're gonna get lucky today!
You bastard.
You did- you- you made it so that I couldn't play.
Play it!
What an asshole!
What a piece of doo-doo head.
What the heck?
I will do this.
An arm.
No, my jokers are full.
Uh, sure.
I'm a guys just like Yu-Gi-Oh!
Get flunky in the tars!
No!
Um...
Sure.
Nice!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Foiled you.
What is this?
be fouls many cars I don't know what that means you're
speaking in riddles oh anyway what did he do eight total
damage five plus ten is increased by each remaining stack of
cars oh okay uh uh do I have repeat I have two repeating.
Wait, I have four.
Okay, good.
More than just regular damage.
We're trying to we'll do that.
Okay, five.
Okay, so 10 damage now.
We'll hold on to our like invulnerability one.
And get rid of that.
Oh, a nice counter.
So shouldn't the thing that tried to stop you until now this
guy wanted to accept your reward be different characters?
Wait, what do you mean?
His HP?
Oh my gosh, I have to change it immediately.
I have to change it right now.
Was this one?
Oh, it befouled.
Oh, man.
Oh, gross.
even play it now you suck oh gosh wait i could get rid of it
cool
oh i would someone that tried to stop you for the whole game
no i don't think it's matter he wants us to win i think it's
like he's like you will accept your reward or i'll kill you
or something i don't
I think I'm nothing I can do.
Ouch, ouch.
Shuffle the tableau cards.
Shuffle!
Yeah.
And that's really all I...
Oh, wait, there was a second one there.
Wasn't there.
I should have...
Oh, I couldn't grab it, though, because it...
Oh, he's gonna befoul more cards.
Oh, and he deflected?
This guy is hot.
It almost
does not feel winnable, I'm not gonna lie.
This does not feel like it's doable.
Like,
I feel like I'm working with nothing.
You have one card to defoul!
I don't want to waste my refresh, so I'll just let the game
pity me.
Yay!
Okay.
Magical barrier that grants eight temporary defense for one
turn.
Well.
We'll do this.
Yeah.
Remove all playable cards with the same suit as the targeted
card.
Oh.
That's pretty good, I suppose.
Yeah.
We're chipping him away.
Chipping him away.
I'm trying to get as much as I can before his shield,
though.
This too.
Chip, chip, chip.
Okay.
It's a random death card.
It's this again.
I'm gonna end my turn.
I'm just gonna save for it.
There we go.
Yeah, because then...
Okay, and here and here.
Because then...
Let's just shuffle.
Ah, got rid of that!
Eight, nine, three...
Nice.
Okay.
We'll even do...
This.
Mine.
No luck.
No luck to get rid of it.
End my turn.
Ouch, ouch.
I think I have to do this.
Trade mana for...
10 mana for 5 health is like nothing.
Nothing in terms of health, I mean.
But it is what it is.
The game gives me nothing!
It's giving me nothing.
I'll do the two random
After this Okay, we refresh the Oh, okay, that's fine That's
fine, whatever
Oh, nice Divine Flash, okay
Wait, this is the one that Multiplied damage, yeah, yeah,
yeah Okay, cool He's resting.
Let's see what kind of a combo we can get here.
If any.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, well, honestly, we don't want to waste it on this.
So let's do this for direct damage and more direct damage.
Will take that one?
All right, and my turn.
Okay, this one is going to befall the cards.
But we have the thing to cleanse them.
King.
Clean.
Change playable card to a Joker.
This one.
Get through the dot.
And we'll do this.
There we go.
Just chip him down.
Chip him down.
Get him down.
and turn okay here now we change the suit of all playable
cards match the target card
yes okay and then you you you hit you you you you wait where
my damage go i feel like i clicked so many oh i clicked a
bunch of like i think multiple cards never mind um much of
anything else
oh we damn it oh my gosh the counter nice that was so lucky
yes and uh i could do the multiplier but I won't.
We'll save it for maybe a really good, ish.
Really good situation, maybe.
I can't really do much, unfortunately.
I'm, like, so stuck right now.
Maybe I should have used it.
Maybe I'm an idiot.
What is this?
Curse cards need to be played twice to remove them.
Okay, well, um, that doesn't hurt me.
at least we're still just chipping it away baby
six damage okay we can tank that
very good very good very good very good very good
uh joker well dude the queen oh i don't have enough mana yet
dang it Maybe I shouldn't have grabbed it.
Wait, we can do this.
Oh, huge!
Huge!
Oh my gosh, guys, we're doing it!
We're doing it!
Oh, this is the one that befoules cards.
I don't know what I was thinking.
Oh, wait, I did it!
Thou hast ruined it.
I have the vision for thee.
The game is not the same without thee.
Now play the Mardle by Delight.
A P-I-P-I-P-T?
Heart?
A p-a-p-p-a-pardle?
I can't speak anymore.
Now...
play in this vision.
My vision.
Oh my god.
How?
The vision.
She dies.
Oh, jump scare.
Victory!
Your Oasis, My Mirage.
Game complete.
Ending 2.
Skip the ending?
Not after everything I've done.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d.
Oh.
Whoa!
Okay, dang.
It'd be really fun if this was the, like, credits for the,
uh, for the, um, the game team, the fake game team.
Like if Shannon was in here.
Oh, wow!
Look at them!
Wait, this is sick though.
Yay!
We beat it!
We beat Forbidden Solitaire!
Yahoo!
Are we now leaving?
Congrats on the victory!
I was expecting a haunted card game and I got Goo Goo Gaga
ASMR.
Spank, thank you!
It ended up not being too short of a stream either, so
that's good.
This could be a Hex Girl song.
I was thinking the same thing!
Oh my god, they're all dancing.
Yes!
The Hall of Handholding.
Ooh, la la!
Written and performed by Graveyard Violet.
Oh my gosh.
Check out our other games.
Yeah, this is the same team that did Home Safety Hotline,
which I do want to play.
I've heard really good things about it, so...
Filmed at Castle of Chaos Escape Rooms.
Wait, that's awesome!
So all the footage was like them in an escape room.
Of the...
Of them as the wizard?
Oh.
Internet connection restored.
Will, answer me.
Are you okay?
Long story.
I'll tell you about it later.
Yay!
We live to tell the tale!
All you had to do was just say no.
All you had to be was like, nah, B, I'm good.
I don't want to turn alive.
That sounds like a lot.
So much for the Hawkeye so fun.
Way to play the hands.
You were dealt.
But FYI, we never want to be reborn in another world with a
different hand.
Do you know why?
Because you're in this world, which makes it the very best
world.
Have fun rocking fan of it.
Thank you.
it yay only we were sub 20 undues that's not so bad yeah not
bad at all a total win 60 baby 60 whole okay that's crazy
you've been to that escape room shut up wait it's a
pilgrimage spot now home safety hotline is really good and
there's an art book post game where the devs explain how
they made a lot of stuff it's really cool oh really wait
that sounds so fun oh cool guys unfortunately i cannot stick
around for so much longer um i gotta hit the hay uh i
thought the stream would be like an hour shorter than what
it is but that's totally okay i had a lot of fun this game
was so fun and just like i said it nailed the atmosphere
perfectly for like these types of old games so make it thank
you You are amazing.
Thank you so much for the pink.
But yeah.
Thank you guys.
Thanks so much.
Wait, fun fact.
The eyeball in the shop was the demon.
You just be...
Oh, I was wondering that.
I was wondering if it was like Shannon's eye or something.
Oh, but that makes so much sense.
Yeah, the eye in his mouth.
Yeah, you're right.
Did you ever find a partner for the Portal 2 co-op?
Yes, me and Vicky are going to play it.
Just our schedules have been kind of crazy.
She's been traveling a lot.
I've been traveling a lot.
So we definitely will play Portal 2 co-op together.
Me, Vicky, Victoria, Roman, my other, my other, well, the
one third of, of, of, of, I was going to say my other half,
but that's not true.
Unless I'm half Phoebe, half Vicky.
And where, but where is room for Minto?
leave room for Minto yeah my gen mate we are we are of
densetsu.exe I think it would be our first one on one now
that I think about it I think some people have wondered why
Vicky and I haven't really done one on ones before um it's
really like and like how Phoebe has done them with Vicky so
much because whenever we are in Japan the three of us
together Phoebe stays at Vicky's house she stays at her
arcade so it's very easy for them to collab um but with our
schedules it's like we have our group collab on the densetsu
channel but um you know it can be tougher for other things
depending on scheduling and everything so yeah but of course
i would love to one-on-one collab with the both of them so
yeah that does help with logistics it does a lot
but um but i told i told vicky actually i was like you
should come to my maid cafe and spend the night sometime so
hopefully uh because there was like some some plans that
maybe would have her uh do be like it would be easier for
her so i invited her yeah sleepover good night meantime good
carding may your dreams not be not haunted with even more
solitaire thank you oh my gosh there are sometimes when i
really can't sleep because i'm like playing the game in my
head does that ever happen to you guys too like i'm playing
a game and like a lot on stream it happened just the other
night i can't remember what it was which game it was too
often it does for you guys too especially with tetrus i like
sometimes it's like i don't feel playing the game as i fall
asleep it's so funny it's especially terrible when you do
strategy games oh no that sounds pretty bad right because
like your brain is like strategizing it's not relaxing but i
hope you guys have very relaxing dreams of tonight yeah oh i
got stuck playing with no let's let's let's power down the
pc thank you everybody thank you thank you appreciate it so
much for you hanging out with me and watching and hanging
out and watching and hanging out and watching what's a meet
all it's a wait all have a good day have a good night bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
Hmm?
T. T.